some um staggering breaking news just
reaching us here at sky center i can
tell you that jonathan van tam oh yeah
you remember him he's resigned
tamara standing by for us at dining
street um wow tomorrow
hello yes jonathan van tam the deputy
chief medical officer has resigned and
that news is confirmed in a tweet from
the health secretary sajid javid
he has just said it's been an honor to
work with jvt and i'm hugely grateful
for his advice and his vital role now of
course he became very familiar doing
those downing street press conferences
urging people in a very memorable style
to obey the rules and of course there
will be questions raised about whether
he's going because of a policy
difference with the government does he
feel it was wrong not to introduce more
restrictions now we understand from this
tweet that jonathan van tam who was on
secondment in that role from nottingham
university is now returning to his
former job and a government source said
it is not to do with differences of
policy but we wait to hear more about
that one